what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch the
official trailer or trailer two or
whatever the heck you were supposed to
be called for Avatar the way of what her
John how are you I'm I'm very curious
and excited I am very curious too you
didn't ask me but yeah all right sir I'm
doing I'm very good I'm very curious
excited to see this guys please go ahead
leave a like that'd be extremely
appreciated also do want to give a
mention that today's video is sponsored
by wondery excited to be working with
them again because we actually use their
services yeah we got more on them after
the after we do the trailer reaction for
Avatar but please do give it a listen
and supporting them supports the channel
and it really does because uh because it
does it's just a fact let's watch this
trailer
[Music]
God damn
oh
wow little one dad
I know you think I'm crazy
[Music]
but I feel her
[Music]
I hear her heartbeat
[Music]
oh wow so close
the luminescence
what does her heartbeat sound like
wow oh my goodness
mighty
[Music]
damn
that was unexpected we cannot let you
bring your War here
cast
that's all they see
I see you I see you
wave water connects all things that's
the title of the move hey before your
birth
and after your death
the circle of life oh my God those
underwater fights are gonna be nuts did
you
with me and I need you to be strong
wow jeez
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that looks amazing that looks absolutely
gorgeous and stunning and I know James
Horner is no longer with us but man that
music who's taking over oh I forget the
guy's name but it's one of his
assistants one of the guys who worked
closely with him it's doing an amazing
job so far and it feels like a dream
come true and you know I kept hearing
about how they developed that you know
technology just so they could do the
underwater sequences I didn't expect
fight scenes underneath that for some
reason my mind didn't go there but when
you are seeing the Machinery like wow
this looks crazy a lot of this looks
straight up like an anime at times yeah
like brought to life in the most
complementary ways that the connection
to life connection to life and the
elements in general the amount of you
know culture and and sort of tribal
beauty that the first movie had is just
like all over this but like times 10
because it's that much more immersive I
feel like that we have something perhaps
pretty special on our hands that could
be very powerful because this looks very
gut wrenching as well harrowing like
there are parts of it that felt so much
darker than I expected it to be I feel
like this will be like 10 times more
emotional than the first one the first
one was pretty emotional for people I
really liked the first one a lot I
wouldn't say I'm like super emotional
when I watch it this feels like it could
go into some pretty dark territory dark
Waters it looks like it goes some pretty
dark territory that I'm personally
pretty excited for there's such a great
sense of wonder to it all and uh
speaking of wonder
thanks to wondery for working with us
again and sponsoring this video and yet
again for introducing us to another
fantastic podcast one that I didn't
expect to be saying is a fantastic
podcast because it's a show that I was
like kind of up and down about there
were some episodes that we really didn't
like and there were some episodes that
we really liked and a couple that we
actually quite loved it was such an up
and down Journey but this podcast from
the first episode alone made me go wow I
already appreciate this show that much
more and that is the official the Lord
of the Rings the rings of power podcast
first thing they took me about this
podcast is that it's host by Felicia Day
many of you guys might know she's like
the most Ultimate Fantasy nerds out
there I personally didn't know about her
until she was introduced in Supernatural
where I thought she was great in it on
this podcast It Go episode by episode
through the whole season and they
interview Talon from in front of the
camera to behind the scenes for example
the first episode is with I don't know
you've probably got very much Clark I
believe the actress who plays
Galadriel she always pronounces the
correct two on the podcast yes while
listening to it I was like wow you know
what I I liked this first episode that
much more ready and I like Galadriel
that much more ready because I started
to understand a lot more of the insight
and the approach due to the fact that
Felicia Day from both just being a
fantasy nerd but also being an actress
as well just gets the best questions in
there yeah I really loved it you're
talking to me about the finale recently
yeah they also had JD Payne and Patrick
McKay who are the show Runners on to
break down the finale and then they talk
about other episodes as well across the
series it's fascinating to know because
there's been so much made out of what
they have access to and what they have
to work with you know hearing what their
reasoning was for why they guided the
season the way they did and just the
human elements of being there day to day
and you know making this insurmountably
big production is fascinating stuff
really I would say that if you enjoyed
the rings of power you're more than
likely going to love this podcast so
please give it a shot even if you were
kind of just like sort of where we were
in the middle if you were like us to me
it made the viewing experience of the
Rings of power that much more rewarding
so you know as they say here to go into
the canals of Newman
watch the rings of power on Prime video
and listen to all eight episodes of the
official the Lord of the Rings the rings
of power podcast for free on Amazon
music you could download the Amazon
music app now I did that so join me on
that Journey Don't forget to check out
the Wonder app or subscribe to wondery
plus and apple podcasts for more they're
becoming like the go-to center for my
podcast so thank you wondering for
working with a loyal customer I mean I
feel like the word epic is used tossed
around so like casually it's like no
other word that really comes to mind for
me when I see this trailer is that it
does feel epic it feels cinematically
sweeping like a true spectacle of sorts
thinking about you know thematically
what they might be dealing with and
story wise seems to deal so much with
Legacy and generations you know saying
like the way of water and and how it
tells a story of before your birth and
after your death spending this much time
and then in this trailer you know it
starts off where you see natiri she's
pregnant and then you're watching soon
like you're seeing the children and
you're seeing parts of the home being
destroyed and devastated you've seen
them having to start a new you know
there's so many different qualities that
you're seeing here of things ending
things beginning things ending things
beginning to have it be called the way
of water or what they're talking about
what the water can represent you're
seeing that just with the generational
Lifestyles or know what the child's name
is but the child at the beginning of
this trailer I imagine that because it
was in in the first movie it was
thinking how you pronounce it that's
kind of the sense of what I get she's
talking about feeling her heartbeat and
such so you're seeing in the first movie
again a generational handoff in a way
not saying like this movie's like maybe
it is I don't know but in terms of
legacy and life and death for the new
life to be experiencing this connection
the way how their father had to deal
with it within the first film and then
getting messages about what to do and
then feeling mighty they've inherited
this war with the RDA you know as
opposed to the navi before them their
children are born into this war and to
be talking about feeling mighty it's
like they have to be born with a certain
sense of strength they're already born
with strength and now I can imagine just
how much more Mighty that strength ought
to be yeah absolutely it feels like
everything is at stake and I think it's
really smart to lead with just the tone
and the lifestyle the richness of the
world more so I mean like you get a
sense for the plot and certainly in this
trailer you get a sense for What
conflict is arising and perhaps
returning from the past but I appreciate
that even still there's a good amount
more focus on just what this movie is
going to feel like as an experience
rather than like oh what's the plot and
everything like that because we know
certain people they've said or returning
who perished last time and even home
tree was destroyed and now here to see
it you know to see part of it being that
we're sort of reconnecting to that
energy and maybe perhaps finding a new
you know home tree for them to you know
Center their entire tribe and culture
around you know after the events of the
first movie it's been so long after I I
feel like it makes this feeling of
return and this feeling of rediscovery
of something truly special feel palpable
and that's lovely because it takes into
account sort of the real life
circumstances and all the time that it's
taken to get here but it puts it out
there in a way that's really beautiful
and that hones in on what I liked most
about the original movie which is again
just the realization and the the real
attention to detail and to just the life
that is this world and yeah all these
talk about heartbeats and Cycles going
you know I thought that was really
beautifully represented by this trailer
and oftentimes you know trailers are
meant to do a certain thing give you the
Flash and the sizzle and sell you a
movie but this just really felt like the
spirit of what I loved most about the
first Avatar and what I hope that they
can make even more beautiful and
affecting here basically all right well
that was beautiful that was absolutely
gorgeous thank you guys for being here
and I thank you to wondery for
sponsoring this video and yeah we will
uh we'll catch you all soon
foreign